Well, I think the several factors are fueling
their growth.
One is, of course, that Asians have finally
figured out, the seven pillars of Western
wisdom that enabled the West to succeed.
My first book was called ‘Can Asians Think?’
question mark, and the reason I wrote the
book of studying the Asians you are so smart,
why did it take you so long to catch up with
the West, but now the good news is that they
finally caught up with the West and by implementing
their pillars of Western wisdom, like free
market economics, mastery of science and technology,
rule of law, meritocracy, pragmatism, education,
cultural peace, and clearly you can see the
impact that is having on Asian societies and
all you have to do is remember that Asians
make up 55% of the world’s population and
the West makes up only 12% of the world’s
population.
So, if the Asians only perform half as well
as the West does, they are going to have the
big world’s biggest economies.
Is this mimcry?
Well, I would say that - I would call it creative
copying, instead of mimicry.
The Asians have pragmatically implemented
what works in their own societies, and it
is not easy to implement practices that come
from other societies, you always have to adapt
them to your own society.
The fact that Asian societies have been able
to do that shows that they have reached a
certain degree of competence in how to handle
their economy and how to manage their societies
and that shows this is not just purely about
copying.